if you've ever wondered whether AI will
replace cloud computing roles you're
definitely not alone so give us more
insight on this topic I've invited Mike
Chambers a generative AI developer
Advocate from Amazon web services to
join me today in our discussion Mike
shares his unique perspectives on the
intersection of cloud and Ai and helps
us answer the question will artificial
intelligence replace roles in the cloud
let's get into it hey Mike thanks for
joining today thanks for having me Lucy
very excited to be here so to start off
with can you please introduce yourself
to our viewers and tell us a bit about
your background in cloud and AI
absolutely yeah well hello everybody my
name is Mike Chambers and I work for
Amazon web services I work in developer
relations and my role is a developer
Advocate I specialize in artificial
intelligence and machine learning I've
been working for AWS now for nine or ten
months but I've been working with AWS in
the industry for about nine years my job
recently has become very very busy
because everybody wants to talk about
visual intelligence and machine learning
yeah and that's why we have you on the
channel here so uh getting into the
question that has been on everyone's
Minds in your opinion do you think AI
will replace Cloud jobs in the future so
this includes Solutions Architects Cloud
engineers and so on well that's a big
question
um my my personal take on this is that
no artificial intelligence isn't going
to come sweeping through and make all of
these roles redundant and we're not
going to need them anymore I think what
is happening is that these tools are
there to help people to be more
efficient at those roles and we're
seeing that happen already so I think
that's definitely going to happen I
don't see not for quite a long time
anybody working as a solution architect
for example being replaced with chat EPT
so I think it is true that generative AI
particularly this sort of new wave of AI
that everybody's very excited about it's
an incredible technology and it's going
to enable people it's going to assist
people to become much more efficient at
those types of jobs so is it going to
change things absolutely is it going to
wipe out roles no I don't think that's
going to happen yeah that's a really
good way to phrase it kind of like an
assistant rather than something that
would wipe out your
own So speaking of the cloud industry as
a whole what do you see as the impact of
artificial intelligence so it's going to
have a large impact in cloud or maybe
the other way around actually so I think
a lot of what we're seeing in machine
learning since like for the last 10
years perhaps really happened because of
cloud so Cloud infrastructure there
you've got enough compute to actually be
able to generate a lot of these projects
that we're seeing so this is all the way
back to things like the emergence of
Alexa and Echo devices and home
assistance so I think that's the main
side a lot of the generative AI
solutions that we're seeing they're all
course all deployed inside of cloud so a
lot of workloads that solution
Architects are going to be working on
are going to include things like
generative AI Solutions and then the
other side is using those tools to
become more efficient doing that job
that could be anything from cost
optimization so you could analyze
everything that you're doing inside of a
cloud environment and say well I'm
looking at what you're doing there
there's an opportunity to make some cost
savings here so if you're writing a
cloud formation template which is a
great thing to do if you're deploying
infrastructure inside of AWS for example
they can be tricky to get together and
but if you can use an AI tool to help
you write that more efficiently then
absolutely go ahead and do that yeah
that makes sense I personally also try
to streamline a lot of the things that I
do with AI for example getting charge
ubt to write some of the code that I
need I think AI has been around for a
long time but only recently has it
started to become more prevalent in the
general population absolutely look I I
used to talk about AI with you know my
family and no one really cared and now
all of a sudden everybody wants to know
about it and everybody wants to talk
about it so as someone working the tech
and Cloud space what do you think are
some of the skills people should develop
in order to stay up to date with the
recent Tech Trends but also try to
maximize their chances of getting hired
into a cloud role yeah okay so there's
lots that you can do I think in this
space right now so no number one
obviously Cloud right so if you're
wanting to get into the ID space then
cloud is where it's at and you should
absolutely be looking at Cloud
certifications and understanding about
Cloud technology but then beyond that I
think we are now seeing this this
massive explosion in generative AI
particularly has made everybody in the
organization whatever organization it is
everybody in the organization is now
talking about machine learning and
artificial intelligence so if you can be
the person going into that conversation
who knows what the technology can do and
maybe knows what it can't do at the
moment and it's just trying to stay
across what the latest developments are
then you're going to be really really
valuable because everybody wants to have
ai in their organization but lots of
people don't know how to do that or even
what it can do the number one tip I can
give to anybody is just have a go with
the tools have a go with anything that
you can get your hands on because the
more you get a sense of how it works
Works where the problems are how you
solved them that's that's key skills
that you can get right there and this is
a new and emerging space there are very
very few people out there who are real
real experts in this stuff so if you can
start just using the technology and
using those tools then you'll Place
yourself well against all other
candidates looking for roles in this
space remember nobody is really an
expert nobody's been working with
generative AI tools for 10 years because
they didn't exist 10 years ago so don't
panic use the technology keep keep
researching what's happening if you hear
about new tools that come out and new
things that you can play with then just
have a look at them and yeah you'll be
fine yeah that was some really good
advice on how to stay up to date in the
field just making sure you're playing
around with the Technologies and
actively using them all right before we
continue I'd like to share with you a
fantastic learning platform called
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes is for anyone who
loves learning and wants to explore
their creativity and learn new skills if
you have specific skills you're trying
to learn skillshare is a great place to
start they have courses ranging from
Tech and finance to productivity video
editing and more for those of you
interested in learning AI I'd recommend
this class providing a beginner's
introduction to artificial intelligence
and machine learning I joined skillshare
to learn more about tech and
productivity and by taking classes like
these I hope to continue building my
skills the first 1000 people to use the
link in the description below will get a
free one month trial of skillshare so if
you'd like to learn new skills I'd
highly recommend signing up to
skillshare for one month of free access
thank you skillshare for sponsoring this
video okay so I know a lot of you who
clicked on this video are probably
wondering and still concerned that AI
would potentially replace your job and
like so for people who are worried what
would be some advice you'll give these
job Seekers and people already working
in Tech
um I think don't panic I think Don't
Panic broadly speaking things will be
all right use the tools play around with
the tools get used to what you can do
with it yes best things are changing and
so if you're a developer right now for
example you would want to be starting to
look at using some of the coding
companion tools that are out there such
as code Whisperer to help you be more
efficient but nothing's going to come
along I don't think and just completely
and utterly replace your job in the tech
industry the thing that people need to
remember and take heart from this I mean
if you're watching a channel like yours
and you're into cloud computing and you
know that that's where the technology is
there are lots and lots of people in the
world at the moment lots of
organizations in the world who haven't
made the transition over to Cloud yet so
you're already one step ahead of a lot
of people and a lot of ID setups so
you're already there and just keep an
eye on what this technology is doing and
as I said before use it play around with
it and get a sense for what it can do
and you'll remain one step ahead look I
think will it replace jobs not really
will it change job yes absolutely so an
example of this is if you're working in
a small data center somewhere then that
job really you need to start looking at
getting Cloud scaled because things are
moving to the cloud it makes a lot of
sense to move things to the cloud that
you have time so you should skill up in
that space in a similar kind of way the
next wave will be artificial
intelligence generative Ai and it will
help people out and so just be part of
that movement and I think things will be
fine they thank you so much Mike for
sharing our insights and expertise today
so for those who want to find out more
about what you do and also the exciting
things you've been working on how can I
find you on socials the best place is
LinkedIn so if you look for me on
LinkedIn Mike G Chambers maybe I can
give you a link to put with a video
um connect with me on there anything
that I do I will post to there and yeah
anybody who wants to have a conversation
about generative AI my door is always
open